У цих теплицях в данському Оденсе вирощують коноплі. Попри грайливі назви сортів, призначені вони не для "кофішопів" Амстердама.
Це - так звана медична марихуана, попит на яку в Європі чимдалі зростає.
До марихуани тут вирощували овочі. Родинне підприємство Мадса Педерсена є найбільшим виробником помідорів та огірків в усій Скандинавії.
Тепер до овочів додалися коноплі. Фермером рухає шляхетна мета - створити продукт, який допомагатиме людям.
Мене зворушила історія 11-річного хлопчика, який страждав від больових приступів.
Звичайні ліки не допомагали, тож його батьки нелегально придбали канабіс. Хлопчик спробував і за 20 хвилин біль скінчився.
Це спонукало мене заглибитися в цю тему. Я розумів, що ми можемо застосувати свій досвід і у сфері медичного канабісу.
Фірмі Педерсена вдалося вирощувати помідори в умовах суворого данського клімату. Коноплі стали новим викликом.
Клімат, вологість, біологічний контроль. Усі ці речі ми можемо контролювати. І це спрацьовує як з помідорами, так і з коноплями.
Разом із канадською фірмою Aurora Педерсен заснував спільне підприємство Aurora Nordic.
Що означає вирощувати медичний канабіс у Данії, нам демонструє директорка з медичних питань Маріанне Нільсен.
Вона дозволяє нам побачити виробничий процес зсередини.
Ці рослини постачати аптекам поки не можна. Спочатку фірма мусить довести, що може виробляти їх зі стабільною якістю. Вимоги - дуже серйозні.
Слід довести, що кожен крок у виробництві - під контролем. І що ми здатні відстежити процес і знайти причину, якщо щось піде не так.
Після 2,5 років підготовки й випробувань Aurora незабаром отримає ліцензію, розповідає Маріанне Нільсен.
Таким чином компанія стане одним з перших у Данії виробників медичної марихуани.
Данський уряд схвалив експериментальну програму, що дозволяє вирощувати, продавати й експортувати медичний канабіс.
Однак ставлення до цього медикаменту поки неоднозначне, каже Тіна Горстедт.
Лікарка лікує марихуаною переважно пацієнтів з болями та невиліковно хворих.
Лікарі часто мають консервативні погляди, і не лише в Данії. Ми довіряємо доказовій медицині, бо так нас вчили.
Однак марихуана - з галузі клінічної медицини.
Це означає, що висновки базуються не на дослідженнях, а на досвіді пацієнтів. Наприклад, Джарег Тиленда після аварії страждав від головного болю.
Тепер він раз на місяць приїздить сюди зі Швеції, щоб визначити індивідуальну дозу.
Я почав приймати медичну марихуану 3 роки тому. Мої мігрені, головні болі пройшли. В моєму випадку це добре працює.
Такий фідбек пацієнтів дуже цінний для компаній-виробників. Aurora постачає медичний канабіс до 9 європейських країн.
Вихід на ринок коштує дорого, і закони різняться від країни до країни. Тому конкуренція поки невисока.
Але Мадс Педерсен вважає, що дуже скоро це зміниться.
Як піонери на цьому ринку ми одразу ж почали засновувати представництва у більшості столиць Європи, аби просувати ринок у правильному напрямку.
До цього ще далеко, але у Франції та Великобританії також стартували експериментальні програми і кількість пацієнтів разюче зростає.
До зростання попиту підприємство готове. Потенціал цих теплиць далеко не вичерпано.
Водночас вже йде розбудова нових площ під посіви - данські фермери готові захопити європейський ринок.